You are no longer a big user of email.
that's true
can you tell me about your attitude to email then
and is it something other people should consider, is it just specific?
well as i said, I am a special case
I'm not...my role in life is not to be on the top of things as much as to be on the bottom of things...
it's best, often for me to be a bit of a hermit and have time for
things that require long attention spans with no interruptions
email, the name of the game is interruption
on the other hand I do impose on other people and ask them random questions
But starting about 1990 I realised that I had started using email in 1975
and 15 years of it was a lifetimes worth as far as I could see
because I had become like a random oracle,
people all over would just ask me random questions
and I would dutifully reply!
Not only that but as an author I....[email ping]
don't want to just dash something off but I would read it off and make sure that my sentences are well constructed
and spelled correctly and so on
so it took me a long time and it turned out that I would start out with
an idea of what I was going to do that day and 4 hours later I would say
'ok now, let me try and go forward after processing email'
[email ping]
On the other hand I sent a question to a guy...I mean I had my secretary send a question to a guy last week
and I am disturbed that he hasn't replied yet!
so I am not being fair
I am imposing on other people
but not letting them impose on me
'Do people bring it up with you?'
The main problem is that they try to go through my wife
and bother her so I have to try to stop that as soon as I can.
It was an indescribably great experience, it really was because there were so many people there who were so good
and the environment was totally open and supportive
If you had a problem, it was like the quarters of the building. Everybody's office door was open
You could say, "I have a problem"
to anybody and they would try and help you, they would drop whatever they were doing